comme chaque matin latifa charge de son
nul et de bidons en plastique qui lui
serviront à ravitailler sa famille en
eau à travers des chemins boueux escarpé
inaccessible en hiver quand la neige
recouvre la vallée de binn tirs elle
répète inlassablement ce voyage nous
arrivons bientôt à la source vous avez
vu à quel point c'est loin
après 30 minutes de marche elle arrive
enfin à ce puits creusé tout près du
barrage par son grand-père il y à 50 ans
un dur labeur dont elle se passerait
bien elle qui habite à quelques mètres
d'un des plus grands barrages de tunisie
qui alimente en eau la capitale et les
grandes villes du pays mais dont son
village et privés une injustice qu elle
a du mal à comprendre nous habitons à
deux pas du barrage le village de
chebeya lots pour le plus proche et vous
avez vu le trajet de la maison ici je ne
parle même pas de la galère que c'est en
hiver avec le verglas et la neige par ce
temps là nous sommes obligés de rester
en haut et de faire fondre la neige pour
pouvoir boire le reste du temps nous
utilisons l'eau de pluie ce barrage a
été construit sur les terres de nos
ancêtres il y habitaient la france est
arrivé pour construire ce barrage en
héros poussant la oi dans la forêt
depuis que ce soit les français
bourguiba ben ali où nos dirigeants
actuels tout le monde nous a oubliés
cette eau est à nous c'est de la terre
de nos ancêtres que la france nous a
revolé pour installer un barrage dont
nous sommes les seuls à n'avoir jamais
profiter de l'autre côté de la vallée
c'est le même son cloche il est 10h et
le père de naïm s'attelle à remonter à
la maison ces quelques litres d'eau qui
vont servir à leur toilette au repas de
midi et aux tâches ménagères du
quotidien il y a quelques années c'est à
lui que revenait cette besogne employée
d'une auberge de jeunesse en bas de la
vallée il a tenu à nous montrer les
conditions de vie de sa famille aux
antipodes des sociétés modernes nous
habitons un paradis où il n'y a pas
d'eau les journées père est obligé
d'aller chercher l'eau à la source car
nous ses fils nous travaillons dans les
cafés en bas de la vallée la révolution
dont tout le monde parle n'a eu aucune
répercussion sur nous j'avais
l'impression qu'ils ne nous ont même pas
compter dans cet événement nous sommes
tunisien et pourtant nous avons
l'impression de dépendre de l'algérie et
à quelques kilomètres nous n'avons
jamais bénéficié de quoi que ce soit ce
n'est pas un service que de nous
apporter l'eau et les routes c'est notre
droit sans devient ridicule d'habiter à
5 kilomètres d'un barrage qui profite à
des gens à des centaines de kilomètres
comme à tunis le plus triste c'est à l'
approche des élections ils se déplacent
tous ici même ce que vous n'auriez
jamais imaginé vous les voyez ici en
face de voir sur nos terres avec leurs
promesses et leurs projets ils se
servent de la crédulité du pauvre
montagnards mais une fois arrivés au
pouvoir ils s'évaporent tous la
précarité de ces montagnes mehrez en a
fait son combat membre d'une association
ils constatent impuissants les limites
du pouvoir de la société civile face à
un manque de volonté des pouvoirs
publics aux intérêts des compagnies de
traitement d'eau elles vont en tant que
peuple on veut du concret réel problème
à l'accès à l'eau dans ces régions
les citoyens les habitants de cette
région vivent un réel problème
concernant l'accès à l'eau nous en tant
qu'association membres de la société
civile notre première mission avec eux
et de porter leur voix à travers des
réunions avec les collectivités locales
et les autorités régionales sans parler
des nombreux recours et nombreux
courriers que nous envoyons le vrai
problème que nous subissons tout comme
les habitants ici mais la perte de
confiance entre les citoyens et les
autorités à chaque fois que nous
essayons d'avancer dans ce dossier nous
faisons face à des promesses sans aucun
résultat nous nous sentons impuissants
les poings liés avec l'impossibilité de
venir en aide à ces familles face à une
situation très grave nous sommes allés
interroger les autorités locales sur le
sort de ces villageois qui se sont
exclus voire oubliés des projets
d'aménagement des pouvoirs publics pour
ali marc maury gouverneurs de jendouba
le problème réside dans le nombre
d'habitants de ces zones reculées une
question de rentabilité face à des
projets coûteux le problème n'est pas
d'habiter à deux pas du barrage mais où
il habite exactement n'oubliez pas que
ce barrage est un réservoir d'eau non ce
n'est pas une station de traitement des
eaux par exemple au conseil régional un
projet d'installation de l'eau doit
goûter aux mines mum douze mille dinars
par habitant au vu du nombre insuffisant
d'habitants dans ces petits bouts nous
sommes face à un problème de rentabilité
le problème aussi et que nous ne
souhaitons en aucun cas que ces
villageois quittent leur terre pour
aller en ville l'eau est une chose
essentielle une des solutions que nous
avons trouvé en collaboration avec les
associations pour l'accès à l'eau c'est
la construction de puits qui sera
soutenu par l'état à ce propos en ce
moment nous sommes en train de
travailler sur trois projets de
construction de puits dans des villages
qui n'ont pas accès à l'eau une
association va creuser trois puits pour
une valeur de 150 mille dinars par puis
que nous commencerons très prochainement
dans le village de al himma à fernana
alors que le barrage de béni m'tir
produit 15 % de l'eau utilisée à travers
tout pays nombreux sont ceux qui n'en
bénéficieront peut être jamais le
gouvernement a en effet annoncé un
projet d'aménagement du territoire de
jendouba en collaboration avec l'état
tunisien la société civile et les
partenaires étrangers pour une valeur de
25 milliards de dinars sur 30 en route
au gaz ou encore électricité un projet
pharaonique dont les grands perdants
resteront ses habitants isolés dans les
montagnes du nord-ouest tunisien